bro forever the three kings that error
yeah
that error that if we went to Nigeria or
anywhere in Africa Morocco South Africa
bro that era would never ever be I don't
want to say it's never ever be replaced
but like it's just something that's it
was a special moment in history you know
and I'm proud
to I feel proud to be part of that you
know what I mean so yeah it's bigger
than that even someone said to me when
um kumaru was about to fight Tyra
Woodley to win the belt I remember that
I don't know where I was but they asked
about the podium like oh does the part
of you hope that kamaru doesn't win so
you could be the first African Champion
I was like what yuck I was like what
kind of mentality do you have to have
yeah that you think like I would want my
boy to lose so I can be the first I'm
like no
that question comes from abundance yeah
when you have abundance
scarcity mindset that's where that comes
from but like yeah uh I would never no
when you come from scarcity the idea of
abundance is incredible right you're
like I want three African Champions
that's the most amazing when you come
from abundance the idea of scarcity is
really exciting so that person who asked
you it is
yeah speaking of African Champions how
do you feel about Francis not staying
with the UFC I think so I feel like
the story is not over even like when um
this whole [__] uh thing or one
Championship came out they're like oh we
are withdrawing from the biddington but
that was a play because Francis came to
them and was honestly like look I got
this deal
can you guys match this they couldn't
match it so it's a safe face they're
like they protected themselves but I'm
not stupid and then when that happened I
saw the The Narrative the the the
streets was like oh he made a mistake
yeah no one said this and that but I'm
like bro
chill it's he's talking about the pfl
give it time give it time let him do his
thing because the story's still being
written also he's the guy that look
before the UFC how he got to to Paris
have you heard that story yeah it's
crazy he's not a guy he told us yeah
yeah we had him on the Pod when we were
in Miami on the way he called in he
zoomed in yeah yeah oh really yeah if I
seen this maybe
but yeah he's the man yeah not here so
he's not going to give up easily he's
not a guy that just like
false you know
give it time give it time I think he's
making the right call pfl also what I
like is even like bringing up the
fighter he's fighting they're going to
get paid at least a minute bro
incredible and then what that does guys
who want to fight they're like if I
fight faster that's a money fight for me
yeah no and yeah give it time things are
happening but give it time the story
will unfold yeah yeah it'd be really
cool to see him come out Victorious yeah
and I I think I'm Champion I think he's
gonna get it done yeah I think also he's
gonna come back to the UFC that's the
thing that's quite interesting no he
will yeah I think just this is business
this is business or is there a world
where the three kings go to BFF I didn't
want to ask if we can add to the fb2 but
yeah
I think I'm going to be in the look for
me uh as a fact it's never about me
people you know like
I've been a fan of the USA for so long I
think this is where my career is gonna
that's it I'm gonna do another [__]
boxing after this nothing like that
regardless of what you say about Canelo
I know your [__] mustache is
twizzling but regardless shut the [__]
up yeah we got to do one we got to do I
don't wanna dude it's limited
in front of me we'll see I never seen
that yeah who's big enough there's no
one big enough for you yeah that's what
I'm saying nah but no yeah boxing needs
a Renaissance if boxing has a
Renaissance wall is just like nah no no
185 I mean like
no he doesn't have there's no money in
it
that's the thing that's the only thing
if there was some money if there was an
absolutely at least let me kick him
not least yeah as long as that's too
easy yeah okay how about this naked box
I can kick I want 30 punches
but what we could do is one round what'd
they do with uh Demetrius Johnson that's
a bad idea if they want a box in the
first round and then they want to do
kickboxing the second round it's a bad
idea yeah but it's awesome awesome
I do well for myself I do offer myself
I'm more worried about the guys coming
up because I'm such a big fan of the USC
regardless of what people might think or
have their opinions about the company
because look this is business and it's
Cutthroat it's Vegas
it's the [__] Devil's [__] but
I want people who fight in the UFC even
when they come into the UFC I wanted to
be like you're being drafted into the
NFL I don't want a guy who's fighting in
there because I have teammates who just
like diamonds going to the UFC
he's doing well for himself but he also
has businesses on the sidebar sometimes
there's other like you have to like do a
few pieces here and there I don't want
that for a guy who has the UFC Banner on
their chest I wanted to be a prestigious
thing where it's like PT's personal
training yeah personal training yeah my
bad
prestigious to be in the UFC like yo
you're a UFC fighter I want to be able
to like you want it to be once you're in
the UFC that's the only job you have
thank you that's what I want so I think
and I
I really want this to be my when I'm
doing the UFC I'm done with fighting I
move on to other things what if the UFC
had a different division in the same way
that like
baseball has different divisions where
it's like here's UFC in America they
have like Triple A Double a single a so
like you lost me basically basically the
major leagues everybody and everybody
everybody's making crazy money in the
NBA they have the G league but it's like
majors and then they have a subdivision
[Laughter]
where the guys who are like trying to
make it into this sorry
[Applause]
it's a question
he's not from this country
he's a foreign
yeah even the Chinese people were like
not Kobe Bryant
look at Drake called um Transformers I'm
gonna send Drake chance my boy you're
shooting the show because uh struggle
jumper yeah
that was a struggle
I'm not quitting my damn job this is
what I love about the documentary they
left in the miss
you could have edited out the
missions
anyway like what if the UFC goes okay
here's our subdivision and you can still
have them on the major UFC fights you
can have them on the undercard you can
have whatever and then these are the top
fighters then all these people that are
part of the echelon are making so much
money and that's the NFL that's
Contender Series yeah like kind of but
they're all signed to the UFC yeah
because D-League and then NBA when
people in the G League aren't making
enough money or are making like NBA
money you're not upset because you're
like oh this is the G League make it up
to these their pay-per-view nights you
can watch a few of the earlier fights on
ESPN yeah and then you have to go to the
paper that's like the way they feed you
the paper yeah it's enticing you feel
like that you haven't made it to
pay-per-view yet yeah so you're right
there I get that but I think the average
person is going all these people are
assigned to the UFC and what you were
just saying is you want the UFC to be
NFL yeah so I think the way to do that
is sign all the same guys but create a
subdivision and then just beg this is
the UFC development league or the UFC G
or whatever the [__] who it was and
then it's just like you know so it's
like yeah you're gonna make 50 Grand a
fighter 30 grand fight but you're doing
that for the opportunity to make
millions of fights even the [__]
billions even just 50 Grand a fight even
or 30 grand for your UFC debut like
entry level 30 grand think about it you
do that three times a year also they pay
for all your Corners at hotel so you
don't have to fly that's different yeah
bro they just merged with WME so 21.4
billion dollar company yeah right come
on you got
what are people getting now because I
don't know and I'm sure a lot of people
everyone's different my UFC debut I made
six figures and I made a 50k bonus so I
was blessed because I had my I did my
work before I go to the UFC I I
cultivated I find my socials I I did my
fights yeah you were coveted yeah I was
coveted yeah there's a difference
between a guy who like there comes in
like Charles Oliveira's first fight was
probably for like a stick of corn
you know that but he's become the he's
become
I honestly mean that and it's I'm just a
fan man I'm just a fan like it's crazy
for me even doing this [__] because I
remember watching the UFC back in the
day I used to go to Blockbuster your
video easy do you guys have that um back
in the day yeah but we should like get
the the old UFC fights bro the DVDs I'd
watch them silver Dan Henderson Rampage
Jackson granny Couture such a fan so for
me to even be in this position now doing
this [__] it's a blessing and I I really
I really feel like it's the it's the
best sport in the world I really feel
like it's it's the it's the best Specter
bro I know the [__] cause [__] when I
when a fighter walks room is different